you know that part of sadness where
you feel like a burden on everyone and
annoying
and nobody cares about you
can we get rid of that part lizzo breaks
down in tears on tick-tock it's like yo
i'm already sad gotta add insult to
injury that i have no one to talk to
about it
on saturday the grammy winner posted
that emotional clip to the social media
platform
getting candid about her mental state
easy
like why do we feel this way
why do we feel this way when we get sad
i don't want to feel this way anymore i
want to feel like i do have someone to
talk to people do care about me
i am loved i'm not alone
that's how i want to feel but i don't i
don't feel like that
okay this is embarrassing a few hours
later the singer posted an
update for her fans sharing that
thankfully she was in better spirits
i'm feeling better i have a really
rough night in a very emotional morning
just
thinking about my relationships and
life and you know how it is it gets dark
i'm definitely um
glad i reached out in any way that i
could
and tick tock was one of those ways and
to feel received and seen and heard
really really helped me i'm not crying
anymore
lizzo added that she was going to
indulge in a little self-care with a
bath
and in the caption the 33 year old said
she was talking to her therapist too
thank you so much again i love you guys
and if you're going through things just
know you're not alone
you're definitely not and i love you
lizzo later showed off
her flawless flute skills and even
called her instrument
her bestie
and she made good on her plans to relax
with a bubble bath
in fact she tick-tocked straight from
the tub
i mean
somebody said megalo does somebody say
met gala and after more fans asked for
updates
lizzo posted another video explaining
what she did to feel better
took a bath talked to my therapist
talked to my medium breathed
um focused on gratitude
um tricked my dopamine levels by
getting excited about something in the
future um
ate cinnamon roll
hot chocolate
um and now i'm
in bed i do feel better
of course lizzo has been known to be
super honest about her struggles in the
past
back in december the good as hell singer
got real about having a few days where
she suffered from
hating her body normally i would have
some positive thing to say
to get me out of this but i don't
and that's okay too i think
these are normal they happen to
everybody
they happen to the best of us i know i'm
beautiful i just don't feel it
but i know i'm gonna get through it and
while lizzo may have been having a bad
day on saturday
i'm feeling good as hell
by sunday she seemed to be feeling good
as hell
celebrating mother's day with her mama
[Music]
dumb dumb rock out i got
[Music]
back in 2019 lizzo opened up to e.t
about taking care of her mental health
and said for her it's all about the
music i
want to feel good like i um when i was
younger i had a friend who was always
helping me out with self-care and he
would be like
you know you're going to take some time
to meditate and you got to eat bagels
with cream cheese and you got to chill
and i was like you're so good at this
you're so good at being happy and he was
like
well i'm only good at being happy
because i was so sad i need it the most
and
you know it's the same with me like i
need this music to be my therapy
because i have been solo and i refuse to
you know live life like that anymore